- C'est justement pour éviter
l'enfouissement de dizaines
de millions de bouteilles,
comme ici, que le ministre
de l'Environnement annonce
un nouveau système de consigne.
- Ce sont sept projets pilotes
qui sont annoncés aujourd'hui.
- Deux de ces installations
sont situées à Montréal et les
cinq autres sont à Terrebonne,
Châteauguay, Granby, Trois-
Rivières et à Mont-Laurier.
Ces appareils vont
automatiquement faire le tri
des contenants de boisson
et ils vont maintenant accepter
les bouteilles de vin et de
spritueux, les bouteilles d'eau
et de jus dans des contenants en
plastique ou en carton ainsi que
les contenants de lait.
BENOIT CHARETTE, min. Environ.,
Lutte contre chang. clim., Qc
- On voulait éviter que
pour le consommateur ou
la consommatrice, que ce soit
un chemin du combattant.
- Québec espère ainsi récupérer
4 milliards de contenants
de tous types par année.
Ce sont les entreprises qui
fabriquent des boissons qui
seront responsables du nouveau
système.
- Les producteurs, ceux et
celles qui les mettent en
marché, dorénavant, avec ce
nouveau système, avec le projet
de loi qui a été adopté,
auront une responsabilité.
- Pour Recyc-Québec, il s'agit
là d'un moyen pour réduire
l'enfouissement des contenants
et c'est aussi l'occasion
de favoriser la récupération.
SONIA GAGNÉ, pdg, Recyc-Québec
- Ce projet est majeur pour
le Québec parce qu'il représente
un point tournant dans
nos façons de faire et ce,
des façons de faire qui datent
depuis maintenant 30 ans.
- Un projet bien accueilli.
- C'est une excellente idée,
je pense que ça aurait dû
être fait avant.
- Le recyclage, c'est souvent
trop limité. On devrait faire
plus. L'environnnement,
c'est super important!
- Ces sept projets pilotes
qui viennent de commencer vont
durer six mois. Maintenant,
la réforme finale du système de
consigne doit entrer en vigueur
à la fin de l'an prochain.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, M